isis terrorists murdered 13 american
service members and killed nearly 100
other people the biden administration
reportedly handed a list of americans
green card holders and afghan allies to
the taliban and joe biden is not with us
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
benwell yesterday was one of the worst
days in modern american foreign policy
history yesterday saw the death of 13
american service members and at least 90
afghans as two explosions ripped through
crowds seeking evacuation in the wake of
joe biden's ill-fated and ridiculous
stupid pullout from afghanistan the
tactics were bad the strategy is worse
the geo strategic implications are grave
according to the wall street journal
more than 100 people were killed
including at least 13 u.s service
members and 90 afghans at the kabul
airport thursday when two blasts ripped
through crowds trying to enter the
american controlled facility disrupting
the final push of the us-led evacuation
effort a suicide bomb attack at the
airport's abbey gate was followed by an
assault by gunman officials said another
bomb attack took place nearby at a hotel
outside the airport according to
officials 18 u.s service members were
also injured the pentagon said to that
13 dead u.s service member numbers that
could actually go up the attack marked
the deadliest state for the us military
in afghanistan since 2011.
so remember the whole purpose of this
operation was to prevent u.s casualties
from the taliban we had not had this
many casualties in a single day
in afghanistan for a decade and joe
biden in signal fashion
somehow
brought about this result pretty
incredible we'd had zero combat
casualties in afghanistan count them
zero since february of 2020
and joe biden pulled out all the troops
and then he handed over kabul to the
taliban and then the taliban allowed in
isis and then isis proceeded to kill 13
us service members wounded 18 others and
kill a hundred afghans at the same time
the attack marked the deadliest day for
the us military since 2011 came just
five days before the biden
administration's deadline for the
complete military withdrawal from the
country and this may not be the end
marine corps general frank mckenzie has
said the military expects more attacks
it is a full-scale disaster area and it
was brought about completely and utterly
by our incompetent foolish president and
i'm not sure what is worse what the
president thinks when he is with us or
the fact that he is not with us like i
don't know whether to blame the fact
that he is senile or the fact that he is
incompetent because he's had these
crappy ideas on foreign policy every
step of the way as barack obama once
famously said never underestimate joe's
ability to things up
okay so
the man has not been right on a single
foreign policy issue his entire career
and he's been holding this perspective
which is that we should just cut and run
from afghanistan since 2010 despite the
fact that the mission radically changed
from 2014 on when the united states and
nato dramatically withdrew troops moving
from 70 80 000 troops in afghanistan
every year down to about 10 000 troops
and at the very end of this mission 2500
troops in afghanistan acting as a cork
in the bottle and joe biden decided that
we were going to pull out and then
everything that happened
was going to happen now what you're
hearing from joe biden's defenders is
well this was this is why we needed to
leave don't you see
this is why okay that is a bizarre
argument so here is my argument my
argument is that joe biden's decision to
leave and his decision to leave in the
way that he left meant that this was
going to happen and then it happened
the proof that i was right and the proof
that everyone who criticized joe biden
was correct is that everything we said
would pass came to pass
that is the proof joe biden's argument
is if we had stayed the same thing would
have happened the evidence of this has
not been provided the suggestion that
joe biden has been making which is that
if we stayed inevitably we would be
drawn back into an afghan war involving
tens of thousands of american troops is
asinine on its face
there's no evidence to support that
and yet that is the entire justification
for a thing
that he did that has now resulted in
precisely the result that he said he was
attempting to avoid
this president is a joke this policy was
a joke
the bravery of our guys in the face
and and women who are there in the face
of what the limits that have been placed
on them by this stupid half-assed
administration
led by the
wanted foreign policy team that brought
you the iran deal and the iraq pull out
leading to the right of devices those
same people have constructed this one
the bravery of the american service
members who have put themselves in
harm's way under these restrictions
is awe-inspiring
obviously our prayers go out for their
families
at this hour
it is unbelievable i mean they knew that
they didn't have enough people to hold
the surrounding area of the airport they
knew that joe biden had restricted them
from going in and performing evacuation
missions they knew that there weren't
enough people on the ground not enough
boots on the ground to even do their own
security and yet they were in close
contact with afghans and americans
trying to get them out of the country
it's just it's it's awe-inspiring stuff
and uh and and
this is the result of crappy policy of
unbelievably horrific policy and immoral
policy it is an immoral policy what joe
biden did here is immoral on every level
it is immoral
according to the new york times
president biden and other us officials
insisted that the carnage in continued
danger would not halt the american-led
airlift that after a bladed and rocky
start has fared more than a hundred
thousand people out of afghanistan in
the last two weeks
estimates of the total dead moons have
differed and we're rising quickly as
different hospitals and officials
weighed in
since the taliban take over earlier this
month thousands of afghan civilians and
foreign citizens have gathered at the
gates of the airport which has a
military and civilian side desperate to
be airlifted out of the country at times
the area has descended into chaos as
people scrambled toward evacuation
flights two u.s military officials said
evacuation flights were continuing
though it was not clear whether any
gates at the airport were open most of
the bombing victims were afghan
civilians including families with small
children
we've been seeing the videos over the
past few days of what it looked like at
abby gay directly outside of the airport
and basically it looked
like a corridor that was completely
jam-packed with humanity
in the aftermath of the bombing the
video is available
the the bodies of those same people are
visible
littering the ground covering it
blanketing the ground
and then today after the bombing how bad
are things about to be in afghanistan
things are about to be so bad in
afghanistan with the taliban taking over
and isis and al qaeda in cahoots with
the taliban at least insofar as
performing anti-american acts of terror
and anti-western acts of terror things
are about to be so bad there
that people are still throwing the exact
area where 115 people were blown up
yesterday that's how bad things are can
you imagine in your own life doing that
you went to a crowded you went to a
crowded area
there was a bombing there the next day
and you went back there to
same crowd you decided to go back there
the next day knowing the threat was
still there that's how bad things are
over in afghanistan and that is
completely the creation
of joe biden
the excuses that have been made by the
biden administration for turning tail
and running and that's that's what's
going to happen here right i mean we are
going to turn tail we are going to run
we're going to remove all of our troops
we're going to leave americans stuck
there
and afghan citizens stuck there and
american green card holders stuck there
and people who worked with us stuck
there we're not talking like a few dozen
we're talking thousands of people we're
going to leave to the mercies of the
taliban or isis or al qaeda whoever gets
them first
and that's the fate that americans can
await in afghanistan if isis reaches you
first presumably they'll behead you if
the taliban reaches you they will
presumably hold you hostage until joe
biden pays them some money or gives them
some more billions of dollars in
american military gear
brought about completely by joe biden
now all of this could have been
prevented even if you believe in the
pull-out which again i think is idiotic
policy
i think that the argument's made that oh
we had to end our endless war it doesn't
count as an endless war when you have
2500 troops on the ground and zero
combat casualties for the last 18 months
in that case bali is an endless war
our true presence in south korea is an
endless war
our true presence in italy is an endless
war when you're not taking combat
casualties and you have a small
footprint that does no longer count as
an endless war
but in any case even if you believe that
we should have been pulling the troops
out
doing so without even securing the air
base that has multiple runways
without leaving enough troops on the
ground to create a buffer zone around
that airport is full-scale idiocy
general mark milley was asked just a
week ago about why we withdrew for
example from bagram air base which
remember we controlled
his answer was
that the the choice was given to him to
go down to six to seven hundred troops
and he was asked do we protect bagram
air base or do we protect the embassy
and he recommended we protect the
embassy
the problem there is the limit put on
him by joe biden
joe biden owns this one top to bottom
liz sly of the washington post reported
yesterday the kabul airport attack has
next hopes of evacuation for the last
thousand still hoping to make it out and
hearing us military ceilings shut the
airport gates the casualty numbers are
growing by the minute a tragedy piled on
a tragedy alex thompson the white house
reporter and co-author of politico's
west wing playbook
wrote increasingly looking like u.s will
end up leaving behind a thousand plus
americans and many times as many afghans
who assisted the united states will have
to try to evacuate them in different
ways after august 31st without u.s troop
presence
the the state department says we're in
contact with the roughly 1 000 americans
we believe remain in afghanistan notice
the language here they're excluding
green card holders green card holders
are people who have the legal right to
live in the united states legal
permanent residents of the united states
remember for for the media and for the
government green card holders matter
when the saudis are killing them when
the taliban are killing them they don't
matter at all when jamal khashoggi legal
green card holder of the united states
is murdered by the saudi government
that precipitates an international
relations crisis when thousands of
american green card holders are left in
afghanistan behind enemy lines this is
not worthy of a mention
according to the state department
however the vast majority over
two-thirds of those 1 000 americans
believe that remaining in afghanistan
informed us they were taking steps to
leave we believe many if not most of
those individuals are nearly or already
out oh well so that only leaves a few
hundred
which is significantly better
well done guys
the pentagon released a statement in the
immediate aftermath giving thoughts and
prayers to the wounded and the taliban
of course said it's not our fault
they said it was the us's fault
the us didn't do proper security
okay all of this is madness but the
truest madness of all
is the weaponry that we handed to the
taliban the trust we have now placed in
the taliban
that trust by the way means that we
literally gave them a list of people to
go kill
okay so let's start with the weaponry
that we're leaving in afghanistan
representative jim banks of indiana he
uh he listed off yesterday the resources
we just left to the taliban
the taliban now has access to over 85
billion dollars worth of american
military equipment
that includes 75 000 vehicles
over 200 airplanes and helicopters
over six hundred thousand small arms and
light weapons
the taliban now has more blackhawk
helicopters than 85 percent of the
countries in the world
but they don't just have weapons
they also have night vision goggles body
armor
medical supplies
and unbelievably
unfathomable unfathomable to me and so
many others
is that the taliban now has biometric
devices
which have the fingerprints
ice scans and the biographical
information of the afghans
who helped us
over the last 20 years
so all that's going well and by the way
if we if that doesn't if that doesn't
mean that we failed here how about the
fact that in order to facilitate the
evacuation apparently
u.s officials in kabul you ready for
this
they gave the taliban a list of names of
american citizens green card holders and
afghan
allies they gave them a list
the taliban the same people who harbored
al qaeda before 9 11 and refused to turn
them over after 9 11.
the same people who have slaughtered
tens of thousands of people in
afghanistan including thousands of
american troops we gave them a list
not just of americans but of afghan
allies and green card holders who we are
about to abandon in afghanistan we gave
them a list so now all they have to do
is find those people and kill them
we did that
according to politico the move detailed
to politico by three us and
congressional officials was designed to
expedite the evacuation of tens of
thousands of people from afghanistan as
chaos erupted it also came as the biden
administration has been relying on the
taliban for security outside the airport
since the fall of kabul in mid-august
nearly 100 000 people have been
evacuated most of whom had to pass
through the taliban's many checkpoints
but the decision to provide specific
names to the taliban which has a history
of brutally murdering afghans who
collaborated with the united states and
other coalition forces during the
conflict has angered lawmakers and
military officials basically they just
put all those afghans on a kill list
said one defense official it's just
appalling and shocking it makes you feel
unclean
um yes
so in just a second we'll get to the
administration's response to all of this
because it is astonishing it is
degrading it demonstrates that the the
greatest power in world history has been
laid low by our own bloated inefficiency
stupidity and lack of moral rigor
that we have decided as a society if we
if we decide to okay this sort of
behavior we have decided as a society as
i said yesterday to to fatten ourselves
up
eat a bunch of potato chips slip into a
warm bath and slit our own wrists as a
society that is what we have decided to
do if this is the sort of
action by an administration we have
decided to okay politically
it's unbelievable and by the way it came
from the top this did this was no one
else's decision the buck stops with
biden biden was the formulator of this
policy biden was the advocate of this
policy biden is the person who lied
repeatedly on behalf of this policy will
go through the timeline in just a little
while here as to how many times this
administration lied leading up to the
murder of 13 american service members in
afghanistan and it may not be the end of
the story in terms of how many people
are murdered in this immediate round
and certainly is going to be the end of
the story in terms of the geopolitical
ramifications of giving our enemies half
of our military technology via
afghanistan as well as the impetus to
move against all of our allies we'll get
to all of this in just one second first
let us talk about the fact
that you can get a special special gift
for the special woman in your life
whether it is mom whether it's your wife
whether it's your girlfriend whether
it's your sister there's just there's
great jewelry that you can get out there
the best jewelry i can think of the best
possible price comes from the pearl
source at pearl source you get the
highest quality pearl jewelry up to 70
off retail prices why because the pearl
source cuts out the middle man by
eliminating traditional five times
markups by jewelry stores and selling
directly to you the consumer they have
the largest selection of pearls
available anywhere in the world each
jewelry piece is custom made for you the
pearl source offers fast and free
two-day shipping on every order
everything comes beautifully packaged in
an elegant jewelry box so it's ready to
be given as a gift if you're not sure
that she's going to love your taste no
worries the pearl source comes the no
hassle 60-day money-back guarantee it is
risk-free i know the people over at the
pearl source super trustworthy i'm not
the only person who trusts them they
have nearly 13 000 five-star reviews
don't overpay for jewelry go to the
pearl source save up to 70 off retail
prices some of my favorite pieces i've
given to my wife come courtesy of the
pearl source also the pearl source is
now having their end of summer sale it's
going on right now for a limited time
listeners to my show can take an
additional 15 off already discounted
prices go to the pearlsource.com ben
enter promo code bennett checkout for 15
off your entire order if you want fine
pearl jewelry at the best prices online
go straight to the source the pearl
source again that's the
ben enter pearlsource.com code ben at
checkout you can take an additional 15
off their already discounted prices
alrighty so
the first response that came yesterday
was the pentagon the state department
said we called the lid no press
conference which is kind of amazing
since it's the state department's job to
you know facility facilitate the matters
of state it is the state department's
job to facilitate the exit of people
trying to get out to deal with the visa
issues it is the state department's job
to do the interfacing with the taliban
but yesterday there was no press
conference from the state department
fine so you've got instead a press
conference from the pentagon the person
who was speaking
via telephone was general kenneth
mckenzie of centcom
and he admitted we are now relying on
the taliban for security that's what we
did we decided that what would be a
great idea just
follow the logic here for a second
we were going we said to the taliban it
is now your job to prevent terrorists
from attacking united states interests
now if only
we had some sort of historical incident
that might tell us whether that's a good
idea or not
if only we had some sort of predicate to
determine whether it would be a great
idea to trust the taliban to fight
terrorism
like let's say that there had been a
power in afghanistan from 1996 to 2001
and let's say that they had harbored
a fugitive named osama bin laden and his
entire al-qaeda network base
and let's say that from afghanistan al
qaeda had then launched attacks on u.s
embassies in kenya tanzania and the uss
cole and finally and most particularly
on september 11th and let's say that the
united states and then approached the
taliban and said guys you need to hand
over bin laden or we're going to destroy
your entire regime and they had said
fine come get us
why it's almost as though when you trust
the taliban to prevent terrorism they
immediately proceed i mean immediately
the taliban has been in charge of kabul
for less than 10 days they immediately
proceed to let in all the terrorists
remember joe biden said that the mission
in afghanistan was to prevent terrorism
i've noticed a few terrorists in
afghanistan recently i don't know if you
noticed it i noticed it among like all
the dead bodies of the babies and the
u.s service members i noticed there was
a little terrorism
that the taliban had been not only okay
with
but um they were the ones in charge of
security and yet the u.s has now been
forced into the position of relying on a
bunch of i keep saying it because it's
true a bunch of barbarian 8th century
goat herders
who have now seized our equipment
because we are pathetic
and i mean our political leadership not
our military our political leadership
and some members of our military
leadership as well because somebody
needs to lose their ass over this
somebody needs to get fired okay and by
the way the person who should resign is
joe biden who's a disgrace to his office
but don't worry we'll get to slow old
senile joe in a second
hey here is the general of centcom
kenneth mckenzie explaining don't worry
we're lying on the taliban for security
and so far it's been going great guys
we believe it is their desire to
continue those attacks and we expect
those attacks to continue and we're
doing everything we can to be prepared
for those attacks that includes reaching
out to the taliban who are actually
providing the outer security court and
around the airfield to make sure they
know what we expect them to do to
protect us and we will continue to
coordinate with them as as they go
forward
they're protecting us now the taliban
now mackenzie was asked a pretty obvious
question which is
do we even know if the taliban let this
happen
because here's the thing
the taliban have real really very little
interest in preventing this sort of
stuff
because as we will see the united states
has no ability capacity or will to hold
them accountable
so let's say that you hire a security
team for a wedding and the security team
utterly fails or they completely fail
and somebody comes in and robs all the
jewelry
you then presumably will sue the
security team right you'll hold the
security team responsible because it's
their job to provide the security
however
if you hire a security team and you
inform them beforehand you will not be
held responsible for anything that
happens
at this wedding nothing
now we're just gonna say that you're the
best we've got and that's it
what is to prevent the security team
from saying two thieves guys go in and
steal all the jewelry i'll split the
take later
what exactly is the taliban's interest
in preventing terror attacks on american
targets
humiliating america in the face of the
taliban weakening america in the face of
the taliban
what is like what is the taliban's
actual interest except they are afraid
of u.s retaliation and if you remove the
threat of u.s retaliation from the
taliban which is precisely what this
administration has done
why exactly do they care i'm not even
saying that they coordinated the attack
i'm saying why would they care if the
attack takes place if you're not holding
them responsible
so here was mckenzie explaining we don't
even know if the taliban let this happen
we have no idea
do you
still trust the taliban and is it
possible that they let this happen
so as to whether or not they let it
happen i don't know i don't think
there's anything to anything to convince
me that they let it happen as to whether
or not i trust them that's a that's not
necessarily that's a word i use very
carefully you've heard me say before
it's not what they say it's what they do
they have a practical reason for wanting
us to get out of here by the 31st of
august and that's that they want to
reclaim they want to reclaim the
airfield we we want to get out by that
day too if it's going to be possible to
do so
okay and um our reaction by the way
here's the the reality
they want us out we want to get out
and if there's a terrorist attack
we're still we're still getting out so
now what's their interest
you skewed the incentive structure you
idiots
you skewed the incentive structure if
there's no retaliatory response
requiring a longer american president
why does the taliban care if americans
get murdered in large numbers or
american citizens or afghans outside the
gates
all right so all this was the lead up to
the
our our absent president of the united
states a fool
a moral idiot
the president of the united states is
not with us he is no longer sentient
and honestly as i said at the beginning
i don't know whether to blame his mental
incompetence or his moral incompetence
for this one do i blame the fact that he
thought through the strategy or do i
blame the fact that he is not with us
it's hard to tell on a day-to-day basis
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that right
now is a challenging time for employers
why well there are a lot of employees
out there and employers have to find the
right ones and they really have to
incentivize them because a lot of people
are staying out of the workforce well if
you're an employer and you need the best
employees the best place to go is of
course to ziprecruiter.com right now
tons of businesses are reopening that
means millions of jobs will need to be
filled so where do those businesses turn
to fill those roles fast they turn a zip
recruiter right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com dailywire when
you post a job on zip recruiter they
send your job to over 100 top job sites
giving you access to their network of
millions of job seekers zip recruiters
matching technology scans resumes to
find qualified candidates for your open
roles and proactively presents them to
you you can easily review recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster according to zip
recruiter internal data jobs where
employers invite candidates to apply get
two and a half times more candidates zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day right now you
can try zip record for free at this
exclusive web address
dailywire that's ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just go to
ziprecruiter.com dailywire zip recruiter
is indeed the smartest way to hire
alrighty so yesterday the president of
the united states
dotted out to the podium took about four
or five questions and then tottered off
he had called the presser for 5 pm in
which he was going to speak
and um
he then showed up at approximately 525
which is his wand
and barack obama used to do the same
thing it is highly irritating on a day
when you're supposed to be speaking to
the the family members of dead service
people
you really should show up on time
okay so that was you know of minor
consequence what was a major consequence
is this befuddled
senility-ridden old man
incapable of running his own
administration incapable of coming up
with a coherent policy presiding over
administration that withdrew from
afghanistan for no apparent reason for
no gain we get nothing out of this
withdrew for no reason whatsoever and
then we proceeded to withdraw in the
stupidest possible way while lying every
step of the way
and now we are trusting the taliban to
do our security
and now we are giving the taliban kill
lists of people who worked with us
this fool
this ridiculous fool he should
if he had any honor at all he'd resign
of course he won't
he is a he is a disgrace to his office
he's a disgrace to the united states
it saddens me to see
our president because he is the elected
president of the united states the fact
that our president is this is an
embarrassment it is a moral it's a moral
embarrassment
he is a his
his presence in the oval office is a
blot on the office and that's saying a
lot because we've had a lot of bad
presidents in the past
this is the most disgraceful foreign
policy decision and an active
malpractice i've seen in my entire
lifetime
and for people older than me it's still
true
he decided apparently that the best
foreign policy here was a mash-up of the
fall of saigon the iran hostage crisis
the bombing of the uss barrack at the
u.s barracks in lebanon in 1982 and iran
contra shipping weapons to the enemy
for no gain actually at least in iran
control we were attempting to do
something good here we just handed over
85 billion dollars in military equipment
to the worst people on earth so joe
biden finally wanders out to the
microphones
and he begins and i have to say
i was shocked
shocked
by his appearance
and
he has looked as though he was falling
apart for a long time he looked barely
warmed over
he sounded awful he was stumbling over
every word he was utterly incoherent
it was it was as though he had just
escaped from a nursing home
it was it was an amazing visually
speaking optically speaking it was an
amazingly embarrassing moment
here's the president this is what it
sounded like when the president of the
united states remember this is the day
13 american service members were
murdered by terrorists
on his watch because of policies he
created
and instead of him coming out there
and looking strong and tough
instead of him coming out there and and
looking as though our enemies should be
afraid of us he looked beaten he looked
defeated he looked not just old but
decrepit
here was joe biden yesterday
a tough day
evening in kabul as you all know
terrorists
attacked
that we've been talking about and
worried about
that the intelligence
community has assessed uh has undertaken
an attack by a group known as isis k
took the lives of american service
members
that's how he opened that was his
opening
and that alone america's enemies must be
drooling
over this
over this person they must be drooling
over the dead horse that we've thrown
out there
and then he moved on in his speech to
paying tribute to the service members
but he couldn't help himself he had to
then brag about the effectiveness of
this evacuation mission
he's still using the talking points from
48 hours ago you remember about 48 hours
ago the administration started moving on
from the talking point of this is a
brilliant idea to our evacuation has
been shockingly successful you know with
the afghans falling from the wheel wells
of planes onto the tarmac you know the
evacuation is actually like we deserve
credit
yesterday the dnc was sending out emails
bragging about how successful this
evacuation was
which as i said on the show is the
equivalent of the captain of that
titanic not accidentally hitting the
iceberg deliberately looking at the
iceberg saying i'm gonna ram this sucker
directly into the iceberg the boat
starts taking on water he rushes up to
the top deck
he unleashes the lifeboats he says
everybody in the lifeboats two-thirds of
the people get out and he says what an
unbelievable captain i am i have set the
guinness book of world records record
for the most people evacuated from a
lifeboat
okay that is what the administration has
been doing so he's paying tribute to the
service members yesterday who deserve
all the credit in the world but he can't
help himself praising his own mission
here
these american service members who gave
their lives
it's an overused word but it's totally
appropriate here we're heroes
heroes
who've been engaged in a dangerous
selfless mission
to save the lives of others
they're a part of an airlift an
evacuation effort unlike any scene in
history
with more than 100 000
american citizens
american partners
afghans who helped us
and others taken to safety
again that's him praising his own
mission
that's him praising his own mission
which is a failure and then joe biden
did what the media loved when he does he
did the empathy thing right and by
empathy it means that he he he tried to
speak to what it feels like to be in
this but you know what none of those
families
would be mourning their sons and
daughters today
none of them if it not been for this
man's policies
so
i wonder how many of them really want to
hear it from the president of the united
states
but this is what he was elected to do he
was elected to empathize not to proceed
with good policy not to protect
americans because we're going to leave
at the very least hundreds probably
thousands of americans and green card
holders behind enemy lines he was
elected to emote he's the emoter in
chief and so here he was last night
trying to paper over his gross
incompetence and malpractice
with a bit of uh with a bit of
sentimentality
we have some sense like many of you do
what the families of these brave heroes
are feeling today
you get this feeling like you're being
sucked into a black hole
in the middle of your chest
there's no way out
my heart aches for you this is utterly
insincere
i'm sorry it is
you are responsible for that policy
you're responsible for like i'd love to
hear from the members of the military
families as to what they feel because
there are 17 million people who've
served in the american military
over the over the course of time who are
live in the united states right now 800
thousand people have served in
afghanistan proper
and i've talked to many many afghan
veterans afghan war veterans over the
course of the last
several weeks
i can't name one of them who wants to
hear emoting from joe biden as he
proceeds to to sully their legacy
subject all of their allies to the
threat of death from the taliban and now
to actual death at the hands of isis k
okay then joe biden had to uh make
excuses for the taliban right so here's
part of the policy part of the policy is
now just as it was with the iran deal
with the obama administration that once
you make a deal with the devil you have
to make excuses for why the devil isn't
actually the devil now joe biden is
making excuses for the taliban so
remember the entire incentive structure
for the taliban to protect americans as
they leave is that if the taliban don't
we might stay and retaliate against them
but joe biden has removed all of that by
making excuses for the taliban because
he has to cover his own political ass in
case the taliban turn out to be the bad
guys we know they are so here he was
yesterday blaming isis k but relieving
the taliban of responsibility that was
the important thing
over the past few weeks
i know you're many of you are probably
tired of hearing me say it
yes
we've been made aware by our
intelligence community
that the isis k
an arch enemy
the taliban
people who were freed when both those
prisons
were opened
has been planning a complex set of
attacks on the united states personnel
and others
this is why from the outset
i've repeatedly said
this mission was extraordinarily
dangerous
and on why i've been so determined to
limit the duration of this mission okay
so our mush mouth president then makes a
mush-headed
argument this is his argument all the
way through if bad things happen in
afghanistan because we took the cork out
of the bottle then clearly they would
have happened if we hadn't take the cork
out of the bottle that is the argument
so if
if we did x and y happened then
certainly if we had not done x y
definitely would have happened but way
worse
i'm sorry but your accounts are factual
no longer applies you did x and y happen
and it was perfectly predictable that
why would happen so by the way he's now
making excuses for why we should cut and
run so there is a bombing it kills
americans instead of him saying we're
going to stay long enough to get every
american citizen out and if you touch us
we will kill you
which is what any normal american
president would say his argument is look
something bad happened yesterday that's
an excuse for us to get out even faster
it just shows why we need to get out
super
okay then joe biden says we uh we're
going to complete the mission okay but
of course he has defined the mission as
getting out by august 31st the timeline
is the mission for joe biden normally
you define the timeline
on the back of what you need to
accomplish normally if i
decide that we need as a company to
achieve a certain thing we then say how
long will it take to achieve this thing
and then we define the timeline by what
we are seeking to achieve in this
particular case joe biden defined the
timeline and the mission is now the
timeline which means a lot of people are
going to get stuck over there here is
joe biden trying to make excuses for
this
we can and we must complete this mission
and we will
and that's what i've ordered them to do
we will not be deterred by terrorists
we will not let them stop our mission we
will continue the evacuation
i've also ordered my commanders to
develop operational plans to strike isis
k assets leadership and facilities
we will respond with force and precision
at our time at the place we choose in a
moment of our choosing okay that part is
the best part right so he says we're
going to get him we're going after them
we're going to
sometime
in the future
later
when i want to
not right now
that's what that means
that means isis just killed americans
and they're going to get away with it
because guess what in three days
okay it is now the 27th in three to four
days we are gone we do not have any
assets on the ground we do not have any
allies on the ground we don't have eyes
on the ground
okay all this talk about how we are
going to go after the isis he
he's hoping you forget that's what's
going to happen here
if that's what he's hoping
of course he wasn't going to say because
for him to retaliate now means you need
more troops on the ground not fewer
so instead he's just doing this we'll
push it off you know we'll we'll get
them at a time it sounds strong it is
actually weak
obviously
okay and then uh he just tells a series
of lies that are meant to make you feel
comfortable but that are just lies
here's what you need to know
these isis terrorists will not win
we will rescue the americans
nope
we will get our afghan allies
nope and our mission will go on nope
america will not be intimidated nope
has four direct lies in i mean five
actually in a row the isis terrorists
will not win they already have you
handed them kabul we will rescue the
americans in there you're not
we haven't been doing large-scale
extraction missions two rescue americans
in there and you've already admitted
hundreds if not thousands of americans
will remain after we leave we'll get our
afghan allies out nope you just handed a
list of them to the taliban so the
taliban can go shoot them and kill their
families our mission will go on nope
your mission is over in four days
america will not be intimidated too late
you jackass
too late
you're the president of the united
states babbling nonsensically like a
mental ward patience about how the
taliban are our friends now
okay there's more of this okay it didn't
stop it didn't stop and by the way we
haven't even gotten to the series of
lies that led up to this because that
this man is a damned liar and americans
are dead because this man is a liar and
thousands of americans and american
green heart holders are stuck under the
auspices of the taliban because this man
is a fool and a liar and a disgrace to
his office
we'll get to more of this in just one
second
first
let's talk about another podcast you
should give a listen to when you have
the time we've got a very different kind
of sponsor for this episode the jordan
harbinger show
it's a podcast you really should give a
listen to i know every day somebody
tells you you have to listen to some
podcast or other and you know i didn't
say sure and then you forget about it
don't let that happen here jordan's show
which apple named one of its best of
2018 is aimed at making you a better
informed more critical thinker so you
can get a sense of how the world
actually works and come to your own
conclusions about what's happening even
inside your brain each episode is a
conversation with a different
fascinating guest in one episode jordan
tells the story of a cinematographer who
discovered a lost city in the jungle and
made one of the most important
archaeological finds of the century
another reason to support jordan is that
the woke mob is going after him because
his show has a lot of opinion makers
with the left it doesn't particularly
like so go check out jordan's show today
it is definitely worth the listen you
learn something new every time you
listen to an episode we here at the
daily wire enjoy the show we think you
will as well there's a lot more here
check out jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or
search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b as in boy i n as in nancy
g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts we're
gonna get some more of our daughtering
foolish old president in just one second
first as the legacy media continues to
spin the news our newest podcast morning
warrior continues topping the apple and
spotify charts and we're continuing our
commitment to bring you the news without
a hidden agenda it's the only daily
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to bring you the news you need to know
we need your help to keep the facts
trending toward number one so subscribe
start listening now to morning wire on
apple spotify or wherever you're
listening to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear i think
you will also if you want the news that
other outlets won't cover you need the
daily wires reader's pass it is perfect
for you for just four bucks a month you
will unlock exclusive access to
editorial content you won't get anywhere
else and right now get a free four week
trial when you sign up at dailywire.com
subscribe hurry because this deal will
not last forever you will find trending
political and cultural topics penned by
everybody from candace owens to me and
matt walsh and nikki haley and pretty
much everybody else take for example my
latest piece here's what went wrong in
afghanistan and what we should have done
differently or check out our readers
past collections different series of
articles on a given subject current
collections include the hunter biden
files and blm the organization behind a
movement when you sign up with readers
pass you also get access to the morning
wire newsletter a monday through
saturday email covering the top stories
you need to know available only to daily
wire members all of this can be yours
for just four bucks a month and act fast
to get your free four week trial at
dailywire.com subscribe it's a great
deal it's also never been a better time
to take it so what exactly are you
waiting for get informed get a reader's
pass today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all right so president biden's lies and
foolishness didn't stop last night
halfway through his little address he
continued along these lines he he tried
to blame everybody except for himself so
as we'll see later he tried to blame
trump but he blamed his military
commanders by saying it's you know we
were all unanimous on this um no you
weren't and we have information
suggesting you're military commanders
we're basically all warning you back in
february march that this was going to
happen and you ignored them because you
are a nitwit here is our nitwitted
president of the united states
there has been complete unanimity
from every commander on the objectives
of this mission
nope
unless by unanimity on the objectives of
the mission you mean you told them
exactly what you wanted to happen and
how many troops they could have to do it
and then they had to somehow scramble to
make that happen for you okay so joe
biden concludes his speech and again
so much of this was optic as well if he
watched it in real time
he's just not there he's not there i
won't even say that the lights are on
but nobody's home the lights are not
even on several of the light bulbs are
out there was the president of the
united states it was an embarrassing
display last night
thank god bless you all my god protect
his troops and all those standing watch
for america
we have so much
to do
it's within our capacity to do it
we just have to remain steadfast
steadfast
we will complete our mission
and we will continue
after our troops are withdrawn
to find means by which we can find
any american
who wishes to get out of
afghanistan
we will find them and we will get them
out so that is him admitting that
americans are going to be left behind
fully
in his daughtering and confused fashion
okay then he took a few questions from a
list as always
and he admits right up front they gave
me a list who is they
you know have you ever heard he it's
such a weird tick and he doesn't nearly
all the time now
they gave me a list
who your nightmares
who gave you the list
why do you have a list why can't you
just call on people
are you incapable of pointing your
finger here was joe biden explaining
that they they you know the same nice
lady who
who who gives me my pills every morning
gave me this list here
ladies and gentlemen
he gave me a list here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc the first person
i was instructed to call on what in the
actual
okay so
um one of the first questions is did you
make a mistake in working with the
taliban
and of course he's like i've never made
a mistake in my entire life
and some criticism uh even from people
in your party about the dependence on
the taliban to secure the
perimeter of the airport do you feel
like there was
a mistake uh made in that regard no i i
don't look um
no one trusts them
we're just counting on their
self-interest
to continue
to generate their activities
and it's in their self-interest
that
we leave when we said
and that we get as many
people out as we can that last part is
just a lie why is it in their interest
that we get as many people out as we can
it's in their interest that we leave
when we say we're gonna leave because
they want us out that part's true but
you already guaranteed we're leaving so
there's no countervailing factor there
if i say i'm leaving no matter what
no matter what which is what biden said
over and over and over and over again
what's the obligation on them
and by the way it is not in their
interest that everybody leaves with the
united states it's very much in their
interest that they have a bunch of
hostages that they can hold over the
head of the united states so the u.s has
no option but continuing to funnel the
money and make nice with them
everybody knows this
okay now it get it it's pretty
incredible
um
he has asked specifically at one point
about this political story i mentioned
earlier that the united states handed a
list essentially a kill list to the
taliban and joe biden is not with us he
is not in the loop he is not mentally
there this is an amazing unbelievable
discombobulated answer
so yes there have been occasions like
that
and to the best of my knowledge
in those cases
the bulk of that has occurred they've
been let through
but i can't tell you with any certitude
that there's actually been a list of
names i know there may have been but i
know of no circumstance it doesn't mean
it's not didn't exist
that here's the names of 12 people that
come and let them through that could
very well have happened that very well
could have happened you're the president
of the united states of america
isn't it of relevance to you whether the
u.s military under your direct command
is handing lists of afghans who work
with us to the taliban
it very well could have happened
alrighty then this is just it's so
beautiful he's asked does he bear
responsibility for this and joe biden's
like this by peter ducey
and um and he says he does bear
responsibility but
but
here we go i bear responsibility for
fundamentally all that's happened
of late but here's the deal
you know i wish you one day say these
things you know as well as i do
that the former president
made a deal with the taliban okay again
you know that i take the blame but uh
it's trump but it's trump weird because
you said in an open interview that
whether or not trump had done anything
you would have done exactly the same
thing
and then of course he poses the false
alternative we had to do it this way
this unbelievably crappy way or we'd
have to pour thousands of more troops
into afghanistan
and also we've accomplished our
objectives which is weird because our
objective presumably was to fight
terrorism as joe biden's about to say i
noticed some terrorism yesterday against
americans
i'd have only one alternative
pour thousands of more troops back into
afghanistan
to fight a war
that we had already won relatives by the
reason we went in the first place
i have never been of the view
okay we can stop it there when he says
that we could fight pour more troops
into afghanistan to fight a war we had
already won relative to why we went and
then later he says we went to prevent
al-qaeda from being in afghanistan well
um you know it was preventing al-qaeda
from being in afghanistan us being there
with a skeleton crew of 2500 people
that's what was happening okay the the
lasting images from this presser are not
going to be any of the things he said
it's just going to be the images and
there were two particular ones that came
out one was joe biden like a small child
being called on in class without having
done his homework burying his face
in the podium essentially as peter ducey
asks him a difficult question here's
what that looked like
no no no wait a minute i'm asking you a
question
is that is that accurate the best you're
not
oh
do you think that people have an issue
with
pulling out of that people from just the
way that things have happened
i think
they have an issue that image of the old
man clutching a binder to his chest
and lowering his head
as though he is being victimized and put
upon
after 13 american service members die in
service to his garbage mission
that is an unbelievable image and then
it finishes with um him saying he has to
leave because you know he has another
meeting for real guys for real
to pull out yes i do because look at it
this way folks and i'm gonna i have
another meeting for real i have another
meeting for real
oh as opposed to for fake
this
what a disgrace he is what a disgrace he
is okay but to understand
the true disgrace that joe biden is you
have to actually follow the timeline of
what he has been saying for months and
all the lies his administration has been
telling because the lies never stopped
at any point at any point
and he's going to continue to lie when
he says i'm getting americans out i'm
getting all the afghan allies out we're
going to perform missions we're going to
go get do you believe a word that comes
out of his drooling mouth
do you believe a word that comes from
this man if you do you are a fool
because we're about to play an entire
timeline of the stuff that joe biden has
said
since april when he announced we were
pulling out he has not said a true thing
this entire way so let's begin this
begins april 14th this is when joe biden
announced that we were leaving here's
how he describes the operation that was
going to lead to our exit in afghanistan
well not conduct a hasty rush to the
exit
we'll do it we'll do it responsibly
deliberately and safely
and we will do it
in full coordination with our allies and
partners
who now have more forces in afghanistan
than we do
and the taliban should know that if they
attack us as we draw down
we will defend ourselves and our
partners with all the tools at our
disposal oh really
um so yeah not a word of that was true
responsibly in coordination with our
allies our allies think we're a bunch of
idiots because the president is
so he betrayed our allies he betrayed
the afghans
we didn't do this responsibly we didn't
do this deliberately
so that was just a lie okay fast forward
to july this of course is most famous
live when he says this isn't going to be
anything like the fall of saigon he's
right it's way worse than the fall of
saigon
do you see any parallels between this
withdrawal and what happened in vietnam
with some people feeling whatsoever zero
what you had is you had entire brigades
breaking through the gates of our
embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
not comfortable i mean that's good to
know it's not comfortable um so that was
july 8th
kidman that was a lie everybody knew
that was a lie and there's notion that
it was like a giant shock it's just not
true it wasn't a giant child okay so he
was lying on april 14th when he said
that this would be a a considered move
and the taliban wouldn't take over the
country and all that then on july 8th he
said that they're not like the vietcong
and this wouldn't be like saigon so he
was lying then now fast forward to the
last week and a half or so so today is
august 27th so all of this stuff that we
are about to examine is from the last 11
days the number of lies this president
and his administration have told in the
last 11 days boggles the mind but they
think that you are a fool and they think
that you don't follow this stuff and so
they assume that they'll be able to get
away with this
the most humiliating foreign policy
debacle of my lifetime bar none
okay so let's fast forward to august
16th
joe biden says the buck stops with him
and the reason that we are leaving is
because we can't take more casualties
thousands of more casualties
again this was a lie when he said it we
had taken zero american casualties in
combat since february of 2020 at the
moment that he said this on august 16th
he said the buck stops with him this is
designed to prevent american casualties
i noticed a few american casualties
yesterday
i am president of the united states of
america
and the buck stops with me
i'm deeply saddened by the facts we now
face
but i do not regret my decision to end
america's warfighting in afghanistan and
maintain
a laser focus on our counter-terrorism
missions there and other parts of the
world i cannot and will not ask our
troops to fight on endlessly
another in another country's civil war
taking casualties
suffering life-shattering injuries
leaving families broken by grief and
loss
this is not in our national security
interest okay keeping 2 500 troops there
with zero combat casualties since
february was not in our national
security interest withdrawing them so
that 13 of them could be murdered at the
hands of isis k that was definitely
international entrance that was august
16th fast forward two days joe biden has
watched as withdrawal has turned into a
debacle already by this point we've
already seen the video of afghans
falling from the bottom of planes trying
to escape the clutches of the taliban he
does an interview with george
stephanopoulos on august 18th and um he
says nobody has died at knock on wood
pathetic
still a lot of pandemonium outside the
airport well there is but look
but no one's being killed right now god
forgive me for if i'm wrong about that
but no one's being killed right now
god forbid i mean if i'm wrong that
knows me
by the way by the point he said that
people had already been killed outside
the air like seven people had already
died during the evacuation by that point
now the new death toll as of this moment
has now stretched
all the way up to
something like 170 people are dead 170
including the 13 us service members and
18 more wounded
okay then that same interview joe biden
says we're not going to leave americans
or american allies behind
a lie
all troops are supposed to be out by
august 31st
even if americans and our afghan allies
are still trying to get out they're
going to leave we're going to do
everything in our power to get all
americans out and our allies out um nope
nope so he's lying then okay fast
forward two days after that now we're
only six days we're now seven days ago
this is august 20th joe biden again
reiterates we are not going to leave
americans behind he was lying
let me be clear
any american
who wants to come home
we will get you home
nope
wrong
lie
okay also that same impressor he says
you know the good news is al qaeda is
not in afghanistan uh there's only one
problem everyone knew al qaeda was in
afghanistan not only is al-qaeda in
afghanistan you know the people who are
actually handling the the security
around the airport for the taliban our
trusted partners over here you know who
it is it's the so-called haqqani network
what is the haqqani network it's an
al-qaeda offshoot
not only is al-qaeda in afghanistan
they're handling the security at the
airport joe biden is trusting this man
is a disgrace and a liar
let's put this thing in perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al qaeda gone
we went to afghanistan for the express
purpose of getting rid of al qaeda in
afghanistan as well as as well as
getting osama bin laden
and we did
oh did we al-qaeda is still in
afghanistan and by the way so is isis
and the people we hand the country back
to are the exact same people who
harbored those people again it boggles
the mind that we are supposed to like he
thinks you are such a that that we
handed the same country back to the same
people who harbored bin laden and al
qaeda and we're supposed to now treat
them as reasonable peace partners as
they go around shooting people in the
head they're dragging people out of
their homes and shooting them in the
head if they worked with the americans
and joe biden says don't worry there
won't be any uptick in terror while the
terrorists are handling the security
around the airport that's how stupid he
thinks you are
okay that same press conference august
20th joe biden says don't worry any
attack on our forces will be met with a
swift and forceful response well um the
bombing happened
24 hours ago we have seen no swift
response we have seen no forceful
response we have seen no response from
the president of the united
states we made clear to the taliban that
any attack
any attack on our forces or disruption
of our operations the airport will be
met with swift and forceful response
oh well then that's um well yeah clearly
because he's lying okay fast forward a
couple days after that now joe biden has
asked a question about isis and he does
what he does best he runs away because
he's a damned coward
that americans face now bye catch you
later
by the way that same day he said that we
had expanded the airport safe zone
right he said this to the american
people august 22nd this is five days ago
and four days before isis just blew
everybody up
we have
constantly uh
how can i say it
increased
rational access to the airport
where more folk can get there more
safely it's still a dangerous operation
but i don't want to go into the detail
of how we're doing that i think you're
going to see they're going to get out
number two we have made a number of
changes including extending
access around the airport and the safe
zone
oh really it seemed like that that
seemed like a super safe zone right
outside the airport by all available
metrics it was super safe
okay then same day he says do we trust
the taliban i don't trust anyone i'm
just giving them lists of american
allies so they can kill them
i don't trust anybody including you i
love you but you know there's not a lot
of people i trust there's not a lot of
people i trust like i don't trust you
the same way i don't trust the team
hey then
his press secretary jensaki who is his
night nurse right that's his actual
night nurse joe biden comes out he craps
the bed and it's jen saki's job to clean
it up
gensake says august 23rd remember this
is four days ago
three days before what just happened at
the airport in terms of the giant isis
attack
gensake insisted no americans are
stranded it's all your imagination there
are no americans stranded this lying
dishonest pathetic administration here's
jinsaki
does the president have a sense that
most of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no americans
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i said when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home who
want to return home is always their key
word there because the idea is that
we're going to blame the people who
remain also we are leaving them behind
clearly
joe biden said it last night
don't worry we'll figure out after we're
out of there
have no resources on the ground have
zero leverage because we ain't going
back in then we'll figure out how to get
them out
so she was lying then
next day she just again this was
literally two days now before the isis
attack she says um this is a massive
success i don't think you guys are
giving us credit for what a massive
success it is for us to load the
lifeboats with people after we blew a
hole under the water line of the titanic
if we dynamited this boat i don't think
you're giving us enough credit for how
many people we've offloaded onto the
lifeboats
i would say that this is now on track
peter to be the largest airlift in u.s
history
so and that is
bringing american citizens out it is
bringing our afghan partners out it is
bringing allies out uh so no i would not
say that is anything but a success it's
she won't say it's anything but a
success
there's only one word you can use for
what we've been seeing according to the
biden administration two days ago and
that's success
just success
so i leave it to you
is this administration
competent
capable are they acting in the best
interests of america's future or the
american people or indeed in the
interest of the american service members
or
is this an administration a clown car
careening out of control with a senile
person at the head of it occasionally
bloviating a particularly stupid idea
and everybody rushing to fill the gap
you tell me
there are a lot of dead bodies that tell
the story in kabul today
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so head
on over to dailywire.com at 7 pm eastern
6 pm central tune in i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin